des objets d'art dessinée est revisité
au travers du digital c'est ce que
propose l'artiste william rolland avec
son exposition regards 3d sur objets
d'art avec les cats et des antiquaires
de versailles nous avons monté une
exposition qui vise à revisiter des
objets d'art à travers la technique que
j'utilise qu'ils aient l'impression 3d
et les algorithmes digitaux l'idée c'est
de ce n'est pas de faire des
reproductions des objets d'art mais
c'est bien de récupérer la matière
première de l'histoire qu'il raconte les
havres présentés sont variés effet en
matériaux biodégradables masques
africains globes terrestres ou encore
bijoux le but raconter l'histoire de ces
objets d'art et du quartier des
antiquaires
j'utilise pour dans un premier temps une
technique de scanner 3d j'ai numérisé
les objets on les a choisis
avec les avec chacun des marchands en
adéquation avec leur potentiel par
rapport à ma ligne de direction
artistique
une partie du travail de l'artiste est
visible dans une galerie
douze oeuvres originales ont été créés
pour cette exposition dispersés dans le
quartier des antiquaires
on a créé cet événement dans l'esprit
d'une balade on vient redécouvrir le
quartier
il faudra aller jeu surtout surtout le
quartier dans chaque vitrine essayer de
retrouver le l'oeuvre enfin elle sera
bien en évidence
on trouvera en vitrine les la version
originale on va dire historique et puis
la version retravaillée
les créations de cette exposition seront
disponibles à la vente en série limitée
de neuf exemplaires